We have a voicemail number, which you can
call really anytime of day.
And there's people who call it at times that
I tend to be asleep and that's fine and we
love it.
That number is two one nine two David P..
Recently on the bonus show, there were some
comments made by producer Pat, which many
in our audience were titillated by, including
about Pat's jujitsu proficiency and Pat's
height and weight.
And one of the people that was very much taken
by it was the egg man who had the following
to say.
Hi, Dave.
I recently learned that Pat is six foot two,
two hundred and two pounds and a jujitsu expert.
Damn, Dave.
Did you hire him as a producer or your bodyguard?
Trelane, brother, right?
Exactly.
And I think that, you know, in in in executive
security, a really great thing is when you
can't tell who is actually security, is that
a staffer?
Is that a policy person or is that security?
So, yes, egg man clearly on to something.
And of course, Pat's training has all been
to develop a very particular set of skills
that will be useful, not intellectually, but
also physically, and to keep everybody very,
very safe.
On the bonus show today, I don't know how
many people in the audience saw this crazy
Jerry Falwell junior picture with his pants
unbuttoned.
Very strange thing.
I really don't care about Jerry Falwell Junior
in any way other than the fact that he is
or was a higher up at Liberty University,
the son of one of the most vile, now the late
Jerry Falwell senior, one of the most vile
sort of evangelical hard right lunatics who
blamed 9/11 on gay people and women having
abortions.
I mean, these are really vile people.
And then now Jerry Falwell in the heat of
some real problems.
And we will talk about that.
Also in Georgia, a teenager took pictures
of crowding in the hallways at school on the
first day back and was suspended for it.
She pointed out how badly things are being
managed in the school.
She pointed out that she's not safe.
And she was suspended.
If you can imagine, this has exploded.
She was interviewed.
And we're going to talk about how she is now
actually receiving threats.
And should it surprise us if Dr. Fouche, his
daughters are receiving threats?
Obviously, a kid who exposes the lack of safety
measures in Georgia schools, given what's
going on in Georgia, given Governor Kemp's
lack of adherence to the facts and empiricism.
I don't think we should be surprised that
she is now receiving threats.
And in the meantime, Amazon, which is a company
that is doing very well during the pandemic
because people want to have things delivered
to their homes.
Amazon is reportedly discussing using former
J.C. Penney and Sears stores, both of big
box chains that have suffered greatly recently
thanks to the online boom.
Amazon is looking at using J.C. Penney and
Sears stores as fulfillment centers, which
there's like a sort of coming full circle
aspect to what we're seeing in the business
world lately.
Amazon now opening physical bookstores, if
you can imagine, after destroying so many
local bookstore.
So all of those stories and more we will discuss
on today's bonus show.
Two ways to get instant access to the bonus
show.
Become a member at join Pacman dot com or
become a patron at Patrie on dot com slash
David Pakman show.
Also, you can continue to follow my training
for the chess dot com POG champs to tournament
with my live streams at Twitch dot TV slash
David Pakman.
And on August twenty third.
The 15 year anniversary of the David Pakman
show, we will be blowing out a huge membership
special related to the number fifteen because
it is, after all, our 15 year anniversary
to be notified about that amazing membership
special.
Make sure to be on our newsletter list, which
you can sign up for.
At David Pakman dot com.
I will see you on the bonus show otherwise,
Tamara.